geschätzte alter vier leute vier leute
vier leute geil
unser team ist kein team es sind einfach
einzeln stehende personen dieses todes
kacke sind in diesem spiel
geil so macht das spaß und witz des
servers zwar richtig geil aber dieser
spielmodus gerade diese hundehalter was
hab ich denn für ein team
die können nichts keiner hat eine
positive kaders nouky & ich hey leute
und herzlich willkommen zu einer server
vorstellung ich weiß dass ich so was
noch nie so richtig gemacht habe
allerdings da ich ja nun oft wie halt
erstmal kein youtube premium bla bla bla
bla schon als ganz oft gesagt bin ich
natürlich gern auf der suche nach einem
relativ guten anderen servern ich hab
einen server gefunden den ich einfach so
geil finde ich bekomme nichts dafür dass
ich das jetzt irgendwie vorstellen oder
so ich wollte ich ihn einfach mal zeigen
die ip ist us punkt mein plex dot com
wir können jetzt einfach hier den server
beitreten und es ist echt einzige server
wo ich so richtig denke so groß dass
geil
also wir können dass man hier so ein
tutorial machen dafür kriegt man 1000
von sodom report von dem man sich nach
etwas kaufen kann
ich habe zurzeit 5054 weil ich das hier
gemacht habe und das land lahm
jedenfalls wird einem da erst mal alles
erklärt wie man in party freuen kann
weil ihr können zum beispiel hier zu
behinderten eltern ihr könnt zum
beispiel party eingeben
dann seht ihr die befehle können zum
beispiel party player und dann könnt ihr
zum beispiel kann ich diesen ja mania
eingeben
khattiya man warte heiße matches nämlich
hätte es geht
die darkness 5775 party wird darkness 5
7 5
so jetzt hab ich den entfaltet das denn
meine party kommt wenn der jetzt an
nimmt zum beispiel dann sind wir
zusammen in einer party und dann kann
ich zum beispiel den spielern und der
joint damit automatisch im gleichen team
und so was alles und das ist auf jeden
fall hammergeil er hat zum beispiel das
ihnen zeigt dahin sieht jetzt hier am
rand noch 46 sekunden die einladung
anzunehmen und sohn prinzip habe ich
wirklich nirgendwo gesehen auch wegen
dem anderen server wir könnten zum
beispiel wenn ich jetzt hier mit weiß
nicht mit max spielen würde mache ich /
party kran kraft dann könnt ihr eine
einladung annehmen und dann wird er dann
in mir ne party kommen da kann ich jetzt
irgendwie spiel reingehen wie zum
beispiel dann hier ist die la carte
bereich da seht ihr oben drüber mal was
das geradezu ist da steht zum beispiel
das skript source london chamber wenn
ihr denkt so auch das ist viel zu heftig
kann ich mir gar nie als durchleben geht
einfach hier drauf und dann seht ihr das
zu ermöglich rohware blass und diese
verschiedenen sachen rollende kuh war
nicht erkennbar und was ja auch machen
könnt ist ihr könnt die uhr nehmen ihn
einfach ihren gaming gehen dann seht ihr
hier champions ist so was du für ganz
komplette also ganz challenge orientiert
dann gibt es mein card also mario kart
in minecraft dann gibt es wie bridges da
gibt es vier teams die immer mit david
norris band also das jetzt nicht in
einer lobby fall mein apartment da gibt
es halt vier teams á zehn leute die sich
halt danach zehn minuten vier teams und
mit vier leuten hier teams vier leute
nach zehn minuten fallen zum rückrunden-
sich zu bekämpfen und so dann haben wir
die art der lettin das grün angezeigt
was da gerade mit dem blog vorgestellt
wird da gibt ganz viele verschiedene
sachen wie zum beispiel know-how for the
bacon wall street source ganz ganz ganz
ganz viele verschiedene sachen und super
special ops finde ich auch kanada werden
die man verschiedene macht eigentlich
etwas mehr sport super smash superkräfte
prof
das blatt am in minecraft mache ich mit
ungespielt place und paar anderen noch
das ist auf jeden fall hammergeil vor
allem das super kropf dieses super smash
bros
links ist auf jeden fall richtig richtig
gerne was originell ist es nomination
fähig das können wir hier spielen
er kann jetzt beispiel hier gucken awo
ist in kombination hier ist es nicht bei
dass es auch nicht bei großen das
überhaupt hier steht auf dem phänomen
action drüber da kann ich ins portal
gehen so dann komme ich in die lobby von
diesen ganzen anderen spielen sollte bin
ich hier drin in combination with the
day schwammig und die falschen players
niederrhein kann hier ein bisschen
server sagen ist halt sehr bekannt sogar
schon da sind immer so täglich 2000
leute darauf online durchschnittlich
sind glaube ich mal nicht auf jeden fall
mehr aber ich find das sie halt viel
besser weil halt wirklich alles ihr habt
hier drin
wir haben hier das jetzt wird am nämlich
erstmal so kurz die map gezeigt hier so
ganz kurz also ich bin team rot und man
kann sich jetzt ganz genau angucken und
30 sekunden das ist auf jeden fall
hammergeil und sowie das ganze halt auch
mal muss nach henderson zum beispiel
diese ganzen sachen das sind so flaggen
obligatorischen flaggen sind dass man
sich hinstellen und dass immer mehr rot
oder blau halt wenn ich das halt rot und
dann muss man halt einnehmen und desto
mehr hat man davon hat desto mehr punkte
pro minute pro sekunde und desto mehr
punkte hat das bestellt wird ein alter
spiel wenn es jetzt nicht zu ende
spielen ich habe jetzt die klasse neid
weil ich die klasse night damit komme
ich einfach am besten
wahrscheinlich aber einfach immer so ich
habe die map hat noch nicht gespielt
aber das ist zum beispiel spielmodus den
ich zurzeit richtig an suchten denn in
minecraft drin es gibt bei mir auch
selten das nicht was in minecraft so
richtig suchte aber das ist auf jeden
fall mal gucken jetzt stelle ich mich
zum beispiel darauf wird das hier immer
mehr rot sagt jetzt an wie zb den ersten
eingenommenes steht seht ihr rechts am
rand unseren score unser set zum
beispiel 91 gema hierüber seite ein
bisschen darüber wenn ich das kann ja
kann ich zurückkommen
ein bisschen aus dem hinterhalt und ihr
könnt halt auch mal ganz ganz schnell
mit rechts ab wer könnte mit rechts geht
ganz ganz schnell suppenessen gegen etwa
draufgeht oben bleibt aber eine gute
taktik kommt einfach alle sofort dahin
halte das gut
okay da ist noch einer von gruber den
pantschen der zahnschmelz ich hoffe der
blaue bringt meinen mandanten auf ihren
verwickelt back on treffer ich brenne
ich gehen muss dann nicht gut jetzt
versuchen wir mal hatte ich mir noch dem
rosa daraus ein anti-held schnauze
jetzt kann ich zum beispiel ich habe
einmal ganz richtig gemacht und jetzt
hab ich 100 befindet zum beispiel so
eine suppe gegessen hier übrigens
richtig gute pvp tag ist jetzt natürlich
meisten sagen hey konnte christa von
schlechten pvp ich bin nicht so schlecht
im kampf aber ich bin also ich hab immer
ohne witz ich habe immer das pech das
ich immer am anfang schon direkt im box
wäre das einfach immer so besitzt das
ist gut weil unser thema geht jetzt als
team und zwar schießt ihn auch noch mit
ab weil sie sehen dass ich ein bisschen
kämpfen bin mit dem so das blöde sie
dürften die von vorne angreifen ist
immer von der seite gehen
es ist wichtig das allerwichtigste soll
das tor setzte sich in meine suppe das
noch ein aus team blöd aber wir haben
jetzt dieses links da eingenommen das
heißt wer zwei flaggen auf die punkte
guckt gingen wir zur zeit pro sekunde
mehr punkte als die blauen da hinten ist
jetzt noch einer von team blau so blöd
dass ich ihn jetzt einmal geschlagen hat
sich in verbänden scheiße das ist blöd
von mir zu dass ich von vorne draufgehen
scheiße da hab mich da hat mich wirklich
denso hatte so jetzt modell das es rates
dass es gab kritische jetzt kämpfen zwei
seiten diese flagge zum beispiel also
mein platz finde ich ist der allerbeste
server ich bin noch kein youtube wie ich
habe zwar schon angeschrieben oder so
aber ich bin halt nicht und ich kann
trotzdem auf allen servern joint das ist
halt der vorteil so heiß dass man nicht
premium haben muss um irgendeinen scheiß
spiel spielen zu können dass sie es
läuft ihr halt viel besser und das finde
ich halt so hammer geld auch nomination
aus scheiße junge zwei leute auf mich
genau wer das find ich halt das geil an
dominierten sie zwei teams sich zu
bekriegen und es geht um was und es geht
darum dass man diese links annimmt diese
oder werke von mir dass man diese punkte
einnimmt und nicht dass man nur
irgendwie gewinnt oder so mal wurden
geklaut
aber ich habe wie viel ist jetzt habe
ich was ich mich denn da team rot 3 1 1
und ich bin zurzeit bester so das ist
von blauen noch eingenommen das heißt er
muss rot war jetzt ein bisschen 1 nach
sätzen so man kann sich natürlich dann
auch in den ecken so ein bisschen
verstecken so so so so so also das wird
jetzt immer mehr zu weiß jetzt ist es
genau weiß jetzt wird's immer mehr rot
das heißt dadurch nämlich punkte ein
unser team mit da kommt einer von blau
und warum beschützt mich dann kein aus
meinem team hier drin wenn man kann
nicht sein dass mich keiner beschützt
scheiße alter ist natürlich total
aufgeschmissen im wasser wg weg das
macht es natürlich nicht so gut
okay doch ich bin trotz mancher alter
mann beschützt mich denn keiner aus
meinem team wenn ich da was gerade das
einnehme scheiße alter gut aber wir
nehmen das sie grad ein
mach das mal so lang bis komm ich ihnen
das jetzt eben zu ende auf man will
jetzt nichts wenn das dort jetzt war
sehr lang aber dann ist es hat zwar
server vorstellung plus domination runde
also nomination ist echt hammer geil
wenn ihr davon mehr wollt könnt ihr mir
das ja einfach in die kommentare
schreiben schreibt man dann alle einfach
nomination die kommentare wenn ihr davon
mehr wollte ich hoffe sein kollege kommt
nicht auf ihn alleine packe ich nur weil
seine kollegen weiß nicht gut das ist
das gut man kann so schnell suppenessen
muss dafür nicht jahre verbrauchen sorgt
so gucke ich doch jetzt einmal hier dann
stoppt man zwar kurz vorm sprinten
heraus schaut echt gut
soll noch ein killer kommerz rate bei
regen so jetzt versuche ich das mal hier
einzunehmen
kommen jetzt wenn du dich nicht traust
als er steht da nur am rand dieses opfer
und ich kann auch noch gleich und er
kann theoretisch einfach halt zurück
kommt jüngst es geht mir drauf hier
draufgehen jungs drauf gehen drauf gehen
rauf gehen
scheiße eltern mein mann mir wird nicht
geholfen wird nicht geholfen alter and
win wenn das der anderen ich war da
einfach im zweikampf mit denen unser
team dann laufen alle einzeln rum das
kacke scheiße alter wir brauchen also
ein bisschen hier jungs ein bisschen an
hier sind euch ein beispiel an mir in
meiner bilanz kassiert jetzt alter das
ist unsere fahne jungs jetzt reißt euch
zusammen reißt euch zusammen sind zwar
alles engländer engländer sind
amerikanischer server was halt sehr geil
ist für mich zumindest als youtuber dass
man da nicht irgendwie bekannt wird oder
so hat zb noch gar keiner kann das ist
halt auch richtig richtig gold
die beiden sind zum beispiel
hundertprozentig rat in skype und
quatschen zusammen sagt der einst so 'oh
du hier kommt ein anderer gerade
angelaufen hilfe brauchen und ich hätte
ihn jetzt zum beispiel soll jetzt als
ich habe ihnen geholfen jetzt muss er
nie aber auch helfen
und er stellt sich einfach eine ecc und
macht einfach nichts er macht einfach
nichts ist scheißer als menschen wieder
tot er macht einfach nichts er steht
einfach um eine ecke und letztlich töten
man muss mir auch mal helfen jugend
hilft mir mal
was ist das hier auch die stehen ja alle
nur um ok dass sie ist zum beispiel da
kann man jetzt eine tasse auswählen und
so habe ich nehme ich bereit
aber es steht nur um anschließend für
einer management heidewitzka ich guck
mal wie die flagge hier vorne noch haben
nabu die show noch creeper und alle ist
nicht aber nicht schauen ob ich da von
proben ihm dienen können
haha luca der killerwal innenstadt
mittelalter schön aber in der letzten
runde da für dich nicht aufgenommen
wurden minutiös geklaut ich habe von
allen leuten die spielen die meisten
kills wo alter der tiere zum beispiel
irgend eine bestimmte klasse die hält
diese bombe dann kann aber dafür halten
nicht so mit schwertern oder so oder hat
sich halt schon sachen gekauft irgendwie
und nidda sei zum beispiel nicht mein
glaube ich jetzt ein
ja habe ich das ist für bekommen welcher
form ich viel und jetzt muss man mal so
ein bisschen hier lang einem ok ok
gelassen sollte aber egal junge ich
helfe dir schalter das schaffe ich nicht
das schaffen nicht ich muss jetzt ich
muss erst mal mein leben regenerieren
dann hinter mir das eine ente so du
kannst du helfen hier du musst dich hier
deinen eigenen weg laufen
bringe ich den alter so schnell in essen
soll jungs jungs und wir müssen jetzt
mal ein bisschen kommt ruhig hochkommt
ruhig hoch alter mein alter verein habe
ich gekriegt aber ja doch ein habe ich
gekriegt scheiße alter egal wann ich
hab' ich habe zwar nicht die meisten
lieb ich habe die meisten punkte aus
unserem team alter die sollen sich mal
ein bisschen hier anstrengen jetzt werde
ich bestimmt hier wieder als loop
abgestempelt nur weil mein team wieder
historisch als die mitspieler aller
immer sind jana schoo unterdessen drei
leute aber das heißt dass keiner da
hinten bei den flaggen ist außer der
einer von dem vorjahr die verfolgt mich
alle geil jungs wir könnten aber
trotzdem helfen dass wir auf jeden fall
hammergeil festhalte vier leute vier
leute vier leute geil
unser team ist kein team es sind einfach
einzeln stehende personen dieses todes
kacke sind in diesem spiel
geil so macht das spaß und witz des
servers zwar richtig geil aber dieser
spielmodus gerade diese hunde alter was
habe ich denn für ein team
die können nichts keiner hat eine
positive kardiologie und ich glaube wir
um alter größten snoopy wir haben halb
so viele punkte wie die anderen läuft
auf jeden fall bei uns aber der ist 0 3
0 0 1 2 468 richter schon sich 963 tisch
kommt bei mir die anderen kicker nichts
wusste
da hinten sind zwei weil ich kann da
halt nicht in laufen oder hinten ist ein
blauer den box jetzt alter kommt jetzt
ein
also es war schön weil oder so
auf dauer aber auf dem blauen da unten
jetzt drauf fdl es soll da hinten ist
noch einer den helfe ich jetzt nämlich
gold aber die anderen auch hier kommt
und jetzt müsst ihr eigentlich mit
kommen hier hin und dass man mit
einnehmen und ja okay da kommt auch das
ist nämlich snoopy snoopy alter ich hab
jetzt hoffnung auf dich gelegt dass du
bestehen bleibt
und ja es nokia bleibt stecken ein alter
wenn ich jetzt sterben die opfer alter
labour springen so groß der andere
schätze alter der kommt jetzt wieder
direkt neben mich ne das ist ein team
blau sind im alter die agieren als team
und was ist das wissen wir wir sind ein
haufen scheiße junge mich verfolgt
einfach alles ganz nett verfolgt
ja geil killer super wir werden hier
nichts mehr reißen können alter ist es
geht glaube ich bis 20.000 mann ist wie
kann ich das denn auf englisch sagen
alter menschen ist einfach nur schlecht
die kann zu sagen reißt euch zusammen
was zusammen reißen
warum lauf warum läufst du hier in alter
was machst du junge 0 1 zwei junge
lerner spiel verläuft einfach rum der
behinderte
kommt jungs so kommen jetzt aber jetzt
wird hier ein bisschen randale betrieben
ich hoffe dass das ja okay der erstes
tod sogar kommt der nächste
der listige stimmt irgendwie okay auch
tut das noch einer damit setzt ihm die
hochkommen ja das ist lukas kubis geil
snoopy westermann junge wieso kriegt ihr
nicht hat jetzt mein team frage mich
schon warum kann ich nicht boxen er kaum
schießt doch alter damit kannst du das
trotzdem nicht verhindern dass wir das
hier annehmen so du bist auch tut
der tod so danhel wir ihn jetzt noch
junge contractor +2 alter 15 kills okay
leute macht das nach wenn ihr gutes team
habt okay ist klar aber ich habe jetzt
15 kills da habe ich den preis gewonnen
weil ich besser war über aspekt bei also
guck mal hier man kann übrigens gesteckt
werden indem man zum beispiel hier
ich möchte auch noch mit drauf da nein
der wieder runter gestellt der puren
bock hier kommt zu mir kommt mir wie
sind menschen wie instant karma das
verdienst an da wenn es denn die
fahrräder auf menschen ins entgeht
darunter mensch vincent vincent
gesetzlich runter von mir danke ist so
fett alter fit und stimmten
was muss jetzt ein generals angst ich
will ich will da hin zum beispiel party
heißt vincent at what have been invited
to your posten
mal schauen ob er denn denkt anderem
zehn anfrage
die party guckt das cool ist wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel a nein du lässt mich
los drücke schiff zu verlassen
nein ich will nicht mit euch ich will
spielen
nein die hunde jetzt kommt vincent ist
es nämlich mit dabei da ist er wütend in
inzell und ich bin jetzt in einer party
und jetzt können dienst wenn du dich
zusammen bei spielen und zwar hier super
super super smash ding das management
wie sowas
allerdings würde ich sagen wenn ihr das
sehen wollt schaltet in der nächsten
folge wieder ein weil dann spielen wir
super smash mops irgendwas wenn es euch
geplanter den daumen hoch gehen und an
die man sich nicht mal wieder ihre ganze
liebe eventuell für 5000 daumen hoch
leicht das morgen schon hoch wenn er
dann selbst bestimmt